thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler nevada's fight against the
coronavirus takes a major leap today
everybody in nevada 16 and older can now
get the vaccine
hector mejia is live right now at the
southern nevada health district with the
latest hector
well today we learned that southern
nevada reached the milestone of
administering more than one million
doses and the site here at the health
district is running again
after a water leak issue canceled
vaccination appointments here that was
last friday but that has been resolved
and the southern nevada health district
here offers the first and second doses
to anyone 16 and older now
the overall goal is to get as many shots
into arms now that the largest group of
people
is eligible for the vaccine and so far
27 percent of nevada's population has
received at least the first dose
however the health district says it's
still competing with misinformation
and still floating out there about the
vaccine
we just have to constantly educate the
population about the vaccine
and let remind people that it's a very
safe vaccine
it's very effective and it's free
i came in at 9 45 got the shot
administered at 9
50 and in and out and it was an overall
great experience
a little sore but you know hopefully no
adverse reactions
the health district opens at 7 a.m in
case you're looking for an early morning
site before work
other large vaccination sites are
located at the las vegas convention
center
at the cashman center over at unlv and
now
inside the encore on the las vegas strip
we are told some of those sites
still have appointment availability this
week and if you don't have
transportation
the health district is working with rtc
to provide those with mobility issues
a round trip to their appointment
reporting near decatur and us 95 hector
mejia
8 news now hector thank you the number
of coronavirus cases in nevada is now
stabilizing it has been now for some
time
today the state reported 181 new cases
and
sadly one death clark county reports 105
of those cases
no new deaths test positivity still
under the 5 percent recommended by the
world health organization which is good
news